[音楽]
[拍手]
気持ちいいねぇいやーワクワクしますよねずっとねこれでものくるので待ってました
場所で緊張もせずに済みます
水でございます10年前某もねー
全く同じ気持ちでした強度ワクワクしておったんですよというのがあの
寂れた温泉街を立て直すために
いい
託されたがんばれよーとねそういうふうにねあの仕事をいただいた時にはまあ今日と
同じようにわくわくしました
いますか
はブスでしょ皆さんも
何にもない温泉街をどうやってこれから賑やかにしていくかですよ
もし成功したらですよ
いろんなところに講演に呼ばれるかもしれないしもしかしたらですよ
テッドっていうねこう言うねスピーカー逆に読んでもらってみんなの前で何か
アイディアをしゃべってくれなんてねお願いされるかも知れませんでしょ
年前のやつのことで弓は見ておりました
本番の程度にはまだ呼ばれておりませんけどもあのは地方のテッドには何かで読んで
もらうなりました
さあ a 街づくり品なんでそれが必要なのかというところですけども
まず最初に皆さんには玉造温泉というものがイメージしてもらおうと思います
こんな街なんです
街の真ん中に小さな川が流れております
う
ビビらんですね自然も豊かですでその川を挟んで両側に温泉がたくさん並んでおります
今16件ぐらいから
今から30年前ぐらいには旅館の間を埋めるように
土産品店それから飲食店さまざまなお店があったそうです
夕方になるとから来廊下なかろうと
お客様が下駄の音を鳴らして歩く姿がたくさん見られた
非常に賑やかな温泉街だったそうです
気づくに入りませんよね
加瀬がしなくていいんじゃないかと思いますかところが今のは30年前くらいの話
10年前になるとそれがガラッと変わってしまいました
あれだけあった土産品店は全員分
シャッターが閉まり可愛い店員が閉まり営業されております
本当に寂しい街によってました
であのワクワクしながらもさあなにしようかなーと思っておったんですけども
そんなあの温泉街させるためにひとりね色んな話を聞いてみましたよっ
の人に胸聞いたんですよ8いやー
安曇郡
なんでですかそう
[音楽]
いろいろ言われますそんな中でだから困ってることないんですかねって聞いたら一番
困っているのはね
早くクールお客さんに困るんだよと
早く来るを受けさんなんで彫ったいや35出玉にねまぁ何か間違えたかのように35お
客さんが来ちゃって触って必ず言われる
矢間の時にそのスタッフ山が思うのは
何もないからお客さん早く来ちゃダメですよ
玉造御膳は5時の終わってから来る所なんですと心の中でこう言いながらもつい
生きたそれぐらい本当に寂れてしまった the
そんな街よね僕はワクワクしながらどうやってこれから再生していこうかなと
ね寝ずに考えるわけなんですまあでも id は生まれません念街を歩いていますでを
歩きながらあーこりゃあ廃墟みたいな mature の店があるなぁシャッター
閉まってこれもう10年くらい経ってるのか
なーっ
ここにオシャレなカフェとかあったらいいよな
またはできないかなぁ
この偽も潰れてるよねこれ重要
年ぐらいだったかなぁて者ってもうカーテンが閉まって
の所に土産品店とかあったら人が歩くんじゃないなぁ床に性をどんどん
会見させていけば
オープンしたらもっともっと賑やかになって人が歩くようになって
ペットに呼ばれるんじゃないかなと
思ってたんですよ
ではなよなまぁそれを考えてたらでもまあよく考えたらこの店を再生させようと思うと
なんぼぐらい買うんだろう
改装費だけでこれ姿勢まあも軽く日からなぁか
さらに得るものを仕入れたりすると最初に2000万くらいからかなーみたいな
とてもじゃないけどそんなお金はないわけですよね
人も宿はなくちゃいけないそんな金もないしそもそもそこに働きたいっていう人が
現れるはずもなく悩んでおりました
どうしようかなーってこう歩いておったところである人を見つけたんです
ちょっと40代ぐらいですかね女性2人組の観光客さんでした
バック持ってでねしゃがんで年かしてでしょ彼はの方向けて写真撮ってるんですね
で
珍しいものもご覧に関するとこんな寂れた温泉がいい人は歩いていること珍しかった
もんで聞いてみました
とっているんです
そりゃまあ見ればわかりますけどね
1年が何をとっているカバーですよ
何撮ってんですかあったらいやそこに水鳥がいてって言うぞ
春の運営してるでしょ
そのとき僕はででまったく理解できなくて水土居を写真で撮るこの人の感情といった
どういうものなのかなーって
で珍しいも大変ですね行ったらいや私の住んでいる街コン中はないですし
3釣りなんかいないんですよ
ところでお兄さん誰ですか私はの観光協会のものでしてでまちづくり会社になってるん
ですね
この街をにぎやかにしたいんですよどうやったなるかなぁってこう歩きながら考えてる
んですよ
どうしたらいいです何か良いじゃないですかねぇ
ですねあなた例えば何か考えてらっしゃいますというので
例えばねあのシャッターが閉まってるじゃないですか
アソコを
壁にしておしゃれなランチだして
であっち側のあの店お土産品店にしてどうにかお店を植え持っていっぱい作っていこう
かなって考えてるんですよ
住んでいる街て
がいっぱいあるんですよ
客さんちなみにどうかこれたに使った千葉からですと
千葉まあ東京にも近いですし私はな街にはもうそういうのがね本当に
毎月のように新しい店ができて言ったりもう最先端のイタリアンとか何やら彼には
どんどんどんどんできて言ってもうね忙しいんですよと
であの普段も回り電車に入られてるんで
多摩あの旅行はもうこういったな
にもないところに行きたいんですそうしたら水鳥が
珍しい
俺がやりたいものやそうで彼をにぎやかにしたよねこれなんですけどねた
普段そういう店がいっぱいあるところに住んでいるからこそそれでもじゃないのに触れ
たいと
俺が考えたことは真逆なんですね
ようなんだろうなと
あの考えておりましたまぁそこでやっぱり思い浮かぶわけです
ひょっとしたら自分が今街に欲しがっているものはカフェとか
まあ土産品店とかは
自分にないもの
いわば田舎にないもの
であり今来て都会の方が喜んでいるものは
に何か
の人は喜びいっぱい残ってんじゃないかと
小稲なるわ
ただ我々とはね前に住んでますから一体何が残っていて何が魅力なのかわかんないわけ
です
ということで私たちはもうこういう風にしました
何しとるかもうしゃがんで写真を撮ったらまぁまず機構とこういうふうに毎日
パトロールをすること365日
あることに決めた理由
でやっておりますとね色んな方が見えてくるんですね
そのパターンをから生まれたもし面白い子だよねじゃあちょっと2つ下で紹介させて
もらおうかなと思いますけども一つ目はこちらです
俺ねあのこれ実は松江市長根先に作ってくれたんですよ
新井があってなんかちょっと透明な入ってあれ
お湯です厳選で鍵をつけるを言うというので作って頂きました
足がありますよね世の中には足湯があるんだったら
l あってもいいじゃないか
ことで最初作った当初はみんなねおおすごい文だうわぁって言ったくさんの人が手を
つけてくれていいよねえって
喜んだもんですよで僕らは観光客さんおこうねもう
パトロールを見張る役割をするものですからパソコンに人が来たら
あっけつけるかなどうなるかなーって
見ておりましたなぁ
ペットボトルでお湯
飲めないのに
院選挙が出てないのに
出てきます
お嬢さん
このいうのがないんですけども何されるんですか
入った
いや飲むんじゃないんですよとあの昨日泊まったら
旅館のお風呂に入ったすっごいすべすべになっていいお湯だよねぇこんな多いはお家の
蛇口変えたらいいよね
でも
無理だよねなんて話してたら中居さんが教えてくれたそうです
いいんですか
新しいやつも組んで会長
line 時使っ帳票
平時はもて通ってそれ
はんなり水買って
まあこういうことがそうです場であのペットボトルにお湯を汲んで返って何する何する
んですか
いや家でタオルとかに来たしてタオルパックとかするんです
なるほどオード
ということは
都会にはこういうものがないから持って変わりたいんだなあということで生まれ
思っていましたさっき組んできたんです
温泉を入れていこう
見えますかねスプレーで5州州州州ぞいま出ておりますこれ
ある今ステージ同様は音声になっています
1 a 4気持ち音声ミスとがいっぱい府立
このように者ちょっとしか減らねこれねいいねなんかでも使いのこれ
は気持ちいいくらい顔にも掛けれます
このようにするとなんと我々が想像以上室ずしている以上にお客さんは喜びまして
a 持って帰るチャーでや親切だわーってことでこれいっ
数百円ですけどもこれが飛ぶようにれて
またあの子に人がどんどんどんどん立ち寄るようになりました
お店を作らなくても
お店のようなものができてしまいました
すべて観光客さんが教えてくれたものだと思います
また違う日はですねこんなことがあったんですよ
これまたあの音声がにはですね彼はがあるってさっき話しましたね
昔からね恋が魚の恋が
自生しよるんです
んですよいっぱいでその彼もの方に対してあの
さをやるおっちゃんあるわけですねパンの耳がなんかこう
持ってきてで言い方になるところに生きて坊
起きて23本持ってきてはこう
これじゃあまだなもう一歩いっぱいパコ
しているように変わりないのかを超えがゆらーと言ってパクパクを打ってくる
たく田舎の日常ですけどもでもあの
都会の人の
が来てその姿を見て何ですかそれ
鯉がいるよわぁ食べてるこんな感じでキャキャキャするそうですよ
であの子の餌をやるおじさんなかなかね
素直なもんですから何したかっていたら次の日
本数を増やすわけですね
ちょっと多めに持ってきてでちょっと夕方にちょっとすごい少し補足して人が来る時間
帯を見上げては出てい
ではだ
ちびちびちびちびないん
酔ったそうですそしたら案の定若いお姉さんが来るわけですねではきたきたきた
キャーキャー騒ぎ始めからね
いいんですかありがとうございます食べた食べたあ白いのがいる
ぎゃーキャッチャーをしておったの
あれ見てしまいました
こんな姿を見てまた思いつきます
恋にさあがやるアレがないんだなとで a
これは今日は服をだけ持ってきてますけども
あのところに鯉のエサを6人で販売するようにしまして置いてあるんですこれよ
するとあの人がですねえこんなところでこういうのにされるんだ
え珍しいってことでこれも飛ぶようにどんどんどんどん開けていくという
は皆さん
こういうふうにですねあの私は10年前ワクワクしながらまちづくりでものは
店をつくってにへ関していくもんだと思っておりましたが
都会の人の話を聞くと真逆のものを求めているということが
年間でよくよく
他にもねー
こういうアイデアでいっぱいあの都会の人の意見を聞いて作ったものはいっぱいある
わけ
今日は時間がないでねちょっと
はいええええ
無い物ねだりですかねぇ
こうして
最初の頃ワクワクしながら考えだおしゃれなカフェ
まあ他の人が実現してくれましたけども
ぬものを作るのは後回しでしたそれよりも都会の人が本当に求めているのは何なのか
緑が綺麗とか
は空気がおいしいとかねさっきもなんか1時間前に英語の日本語の上手な外国人の人が
言ってましたね
空気がおいしいとがすごい素晴らしいとかまあそういうところに都会の人のないものを
補うまだまだ残されていることに気がついたらいろんなものを生まれてくるんじゃない
かなと思っております
ということで今日もですね本当はパトロールに行きたいわけですよもう時間になって
おりますので
これ喋ってるバーン
まあ by じゃあないですねもう本当は
ということでの時間になりましたので皆さん今が